how's going breasts my name is Paora bad
welcome back to amnesia the Dark Descent
followed by that I kind of feel like I'm
back I recovered from the last door
explosion experience my headphones are
not work there we go
we're gonna go in the I was a card table
to Bala I which means office in I don't
trust you man I just don't do it you
will die [ __ ]
oh it's gonna throw him at the window
kids are the office let's go what's
going on here hole in the wall sharing
the secrets a bit duck maybe beautiful
back here you go show you can have it
all right oh you want this - yeah whoa
Jesus something going on here
barrels what are you doing well black as
a hatch there
it's got a cool
I'll get damned he's got swag
should have no non-aligned got a putt
thank god you're back
I'll put you down don't you dare break
on me this is a maybe I need the crowbar
here no hmm lamp
don't [ __ ] with me no all right
guess what what's going on what what was
that hello he left the closet
oh sorry bud take a minute why would he
just flip a closet like that why did the
closet ever do to you man
okay came here he playing the piano
again that's a little [ __ ] I told him
not to play with my yeah why the [ __ ] do
I have oh oh oh oh
we are going back to the house and then
we're going down in the basement 9 show
and then last episode but there's like
this basement I had no idea what I was
doing there but there was a door and I
guess who can use the crowbar I think
sorry
I hope cap damn noises freaked me out
and it's sugar sniffer rip around it and
the things are forever
well I'm sure well I'll come on
stupid do no one likes you
that rhymed - because I am blue Oh rap
career
incoming Francis whispered was in front
of I always play along Henry William
David's here wanted to smear and peer
yeah I'm such a good rapper rhymer riot
Riddler room I'm sorry
there we go uh-huh uh-huh
everything seems to be now don't hell
out of that red goo had a barrel fire
your day today
ha ha ha don't you dare all right this
please work yes
laughter you see that [ __ ] barrel oh
don't you dare come near me
don't you dare [ __ ] off alright that
rolling sound come on
it's [ __ ] oh there we go hello
I don't like this man
not one bit okay now isn't it nice
wallpapers love it love that love that
crazy barrels what are you doing here
Jennifer don't disturb me potato
everyone so many barrels all right I'm
just gonna grab the chemistry stuff all
right I got what I wanted I don't want
anything else anything out nothing out
nothing yes
oh no no no no take the barrels take the
boughs take your barrels take them if
you do turbo mode activated turbo mode
is activated
holy [ __ ] [ __ ] II sniffing like an
ass
why I ever did it have
stupid ass huh I don't need him I know
aa-actually feel safe now I mean
whoa now I hate
everyone just calm down nice little cozy
place you got here mr. Chang
Thank you very I like it I college my
sexytime what you don't even make sense
sometimes Hey yeah I palm tree whoa I'm
too high well do it do it down [ __ ] with
me where where where okay yeah I am the
big in that year
I'm pump and pump and shall forgive me
okay we need to find a lever I think
let's go yeah big big guess who's back
back again pig is back huh scandal I
mean friend burgers back PA piggy
sup foodie I miss you I miss you you
need to pull that lever I'll do it
alright see you later man roughest man
alright come no I know what I did that
yeah well
where am I
big game what's going down here catch
anybody
[Applause]
[Applause]
you mustn't give up up what am I
supposed to do there tell me I like to
know piggy
let me kill [ __ ] this [ __ ] I love Hey
look everyone just acquired quite stuff
mud
all right oh I am sweating like a pig
right now yeah yeah what are these
puzzle parts thank God Jesus thank God
for puss apart spin the wheel I'm
feeling brand new look I'm spinning like
a boss can't you see not a sugar ha I
open that
Wow hey well look at that I got I got a
hiccup hey noodles
hey chains uh whatever you are can you
climb Daniel please thank you you're so
sweet
Daniel you're on bad you Daniel
I don't know buddy man what what what
Jennifer why did you do that
I'm Jamie you're not saving any men man
oh my god I don't care all right give me
that just presents for you
what what I don't trust anything right
now but I got my red hot rod Dell
let's go up here I guess start slow Wow
okay again yeah what the hell are you
doing that Daniel that is not how you
climb a ladder huh
I instructed you before we started this
video you do not climb ladders by doing
that there we go well that wasn't what
the [ __ ] just happened
don't want to know why did I slap myself
what yeah
ready go are you there hey um so you say
I'm so [ __ ] jumpy today all right so
we got a red rod I don't know what they
are used for but this is the second room
I have a gate can we all the locks gate
- all right oh okay cool
hi that's pretty a collection it looks
like this machine is connected
and let's spin the wheel I guess like we
always do don't you - say it
Wow all right here we go
cool nice office Hey Oh No
Oh God
this walkthrough here I guess where's
the lather whatever I guess we got a
guac fitter this disgusting huh love
Jennifer Jennifer I know you love me
[Music]
what all right not that penis monster
alright let's go down here I guess
[ __ ] cockroaches man hope I don't run
into a dead end or something this riser
penumbra
do you remember for numbre overture you
walk through the out long ago man long
ago and we are back ladies and gentlemen
all right so that's unlock its face and
the next steps are back vision guy this
guy to come right today and I'll see you
next video that I have try to make
that's pretty much it
sales embrace well what the hell they
see me rollin they hatin but they [ __ ]
you I mean mate if they [ __ ] off [ __ ]
off back